if you ignore these YouTube tips you're
probably going to regret it later
whether you just struggle and stay stuck
not getting views or if currently your
YouTube channel has hit a plateau it's
probably because of one of the seven
mistakes we're gonna talk about in this
podcast episode
number one not embracing YouTube shorts
listen YouTube shorts are getting 30
billion views per day that's a 4X
increase from the previous stat and that
was reported at the beginning of 2022.
so these numbers continue to go up not
only that YouTube shorts is now getting
monetization so you can earn money
drawing creators from other platforms
and YouTube is going all in on YouTube
shorts so can you succeed without using
YouTube shorts sure but why would you
put yourself at a disadvantage when your
competitors and other creators are
embracing this new median you know
there's a Creator name Taylin Michael
who is a Christian content creator he
grew 1.1 million subscribers in 28 days
from going all in on YouTube shorts am I
saying it has to be the only kind of
content you create no am I say saying
that it should be some of the content
that you create yes short form content
is a gateway to long form and YouTube is
now better organized separating your
videos your shorts and live streams I
just believe that if you ignore YouTube
shorts and if you refuse to learn how to
storytell and create content in less
than 60 seconds in a vertical format or
to repurpose your content strategically
you are going to regret it later and
you're going to get left behind number
two
not learning from others it is foolish
to not learn from others who could we
learn from I think it's worth looking at
your competitors now what I'm not
talking about is comparison comparison
is the thief of joy and it is the killer
of creativity however there's a great
concept from Simon sinek that is called
worthy Rivals by having people who are
Rivals that inspire you to push harder
people that you learn from and people
that with a healthy respect you pull
inspiration and information and strategy
from so what competitors are you
studying in your Niche are you consuming
enough YouTube who would have thought
that actually watching YouTube now has a
business purpose and a strategic purpose
because you're watching to see what
works not just to be entertained you're
watching not to just learn the substance
of the video itself but even the way the
video is being created and how the
videos be he is performing what is
YouTube recommending to you what
thumbnails do you want to click on
and of course not continuing to invest
in your education lifelong leaders are
lifelong Learners I found those that
ignore learning from others and at some
point they stop getting wisdom and they
stop taking notes and they stop going to
events and they stop reading books those
are the ones that years later find
themselves further and further behind if
you want to win you got to continue to
learn and the only way to win is to
learn faster than anybody else number
three not listening to your audience
when you stop listening to your audience
you start getting out of touch not
listening to your audience and
also on number three not listening to
your Analytics
so we've all heard that the definition
of insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
if you're listening to your analytics
you can then make data-driven decisions
to be informed about the next thing you
should do better ultimately I don't even
really believe in failures I believe in
lessons that can lead you to success now
sure a video may have failed but really
what it did was it educated you and
informed you on what not to do next time
and even your most successful videos
contain lessons as you study your
analytics creators that say Sean I've
had 100 videos I'm at 200 videos I'm at
300 videos on YouTube and I'm still
stuck you're not listening to your
analytics you're not studying your watch
time curve you're not listening to the
comments or maybe you're not getting
comments something needs to change but
if you're not listening and you're just
blindly continuing on the same path
expecting a different result you might
be insane it's the definition of
insanity furthermore not listening to
your audio I am stunned by creators that
start to grow and have some success that
stop reading comments that stop
listening to the feedback they're
getting on the community tab that stop
if you're posting on other social media
platforms listening and I understand I'm
empathetic things get busy as your
business gets more complex a lot of
mid-level creators that start
experiencing success maybe high five
multiple six figures of income a lot of
times get so overwhelmed because of
lacking leadership skills or team
building skills or operational skills or
business skills or organizational skills
um that I get it it's daunting and it's
overwhelming and then you're still
trying to create content but the problem
is when you were starting and hustling
and valuing every View and every comment
now you're out of touch I find myself
I'm still in my YouTube studio app I'm
still in the comments you know if you
listen to the think media podcast I read
every review if you watch the think
media podcast on YouTube I at least read
every comment when you see those hearts
showing up in those comments I'm there I
am replying to the comments we also have
Team helping us but I I rotate around
platforms and I can't get to everything
but I learned from Andy Stanley do for
one which you wish you could do for all
and more importantly yes I want to reply
or I want to heart or I want to like the
comment but I also just need to make
sure I'm listening why because that's
where the insights come from when a new
video comes out I listen if someone
starts saying this seems out of touch
you missed it on this one if it's just
one person I'll take that with a grain
of salt but if it's ten percent twenty
percent forty percent of the comments
are like you're off here I at least need
to pay attention don't we need to have
the humility and the empathy to listen
to feedback from our community listen
I've seen people that ignore this
YouTube tip and they regret it later
they find themselves drifting further
and further and further out of touch
with their audience and then they start
to see their stats and their relevance
decline you got to listen to your
audience and you got to listen to your
analytics number four not having a plan
or a strategy those that just go onto
YouTube guns blazing with no plan
end up losing now listen I know you got
to just punch fear in the face and press
record and that sounds like you do that
before you're ready you start messy you
start poop your pants scared you can't
steer a parked car of course your first
couple videos you gotta just get moving
because overthinking and procrastination
is what's holding you back so what
you're trying to do is create a little
bit of momentum because truly you cannot
steer a parked car like it's not that I
mean nowadays you have power steering
but literally the car needs some
movement I was looking at a bus driver
today and I was seeing how big his
steering wheel was and I was thinking of
course he has power steering but he was
I was like that's a physical job I was
as I was watching him take this corner
down in Lynnwood Washington I was like
that's that's an athletic job even with
the power steering to steer this thing
because it's this giant vehicle this
giant double decker bus that he was
driving what's the point
the point is that you need a little bit
of movement so you can start steering
but once you get moving where are you
going
aren't you going to enter a address in
your GPS and your phone you've defined a
destination
and then your GPS is actually telling
you turn here go right here don't go
here go here you missed a turn rerouting
and that's what we need on YouTube we
need to know where we're going and then
we need the play-by-play left on 17th a
ride on Pine Street whoops missed it
we're gonna make mistakes along the way
rerouting and we get back on track
towards our destination
those that don't have a plan lose on
YouTube those that all have a strategy
lose on YouTube
you know in a 2023 world it's more
important than ever to be strategic
a lot of creators are still kind of
playing by some of the old rules they
haven't continued to learn they haven't
continued to get educated or maybe
they're starting and just thinking I'm
just gonna wing it
and friend that just doesn't work in a
2023 World a lot of creators are trying
to play Checkers when you need to be
playing chess
a whole nother level of strategy and by
the way if you haven't heard yet and you
want specific help helping you with
strategy helping you develop a winning
YouTube plan as well as get access to a
community at a deeper level at think
media our signature program is called
video ranking Academy and a few times a
year we do like a super special offer
with some special bonuses and all this
other stuff we do that during our five
day challenges and you may or may not
have been a part of that but right now
for a very limited time we actually are
doing our best offer of the year on our
signature course some cool bonuses
access to our private group and if
that's something that you're interested
in you can check it out at
learnvideo2023.com of course there's a
link in the show notes as well that's
directly to a place where you can invest
in this and it's not cheap it's uh it's
a real investment but the value that
you're getting this is like YouTube
college and community
with updates you get a lot of cool
things that are happening and if you
basically say this if you valued your
time
and you want to go faster you don't want
to just figure it out on your own you
want a step-by-step Playbook to win on
YouTube and you understand the power of
community knowing that information alone
is not enough we need a community to
keep us inspired to bounce ideas off
it's cool because you have access to me
and our think media faculty and our
YouTube coaches and so anyways super
cool if you want more help with having a
plan having a strategy learn video
2023.com you can check out that there
but number five is not being consistent
before you go I've heard this one before
there's deeper levels to consistency in
fact I'm convinced 99 of creators don't
even understand what consistency is
see they think oh being consistent I
gotta upload once a week I need to
upload at least twice a week I'm
uploading one video and one YouTube
short that's not what consistency is
that's a piece of it that's only like 10
percent though
see where people fail the mistake they
make is it's not just about having a
consistent upload time it's also about
having a consistent brand
if every time I see you online you're
indistinguishable I can't recognize you
I have no idea what you're talking about
you're forgettable
like I'm not seeing consistency in the
look I'm not seeing consistency in the
video quality in the brand in the music
in the mood and the emotion because
again we're forgetful people we're super
busy so if you constantly are looking
different by the way this is I was like
losing my mind when I thought about
growing a beard and so now I've had this
beard for a while it's you know a little
bit of gray came in with it I was like I
don't know if I like it my wife liked it
and I was like babe if you like it then
then that's what I'm gonna do you know
and so she was into it so I I went ahead
and grew it out but I was like am I
destroying my brand because me without a
beard I look 10 years younger like a
child than with the beard I'm look 10
years older as like you know and so
these are things to be thoughtful about
like you don't need to over think but
you're not just showing up at a
consistent time you want to show up with
a consistent look you want to be
memorable
you want to show up with a consistent
message
too many people I see one day they're
like subscribe for cooking tutorials and
then you know two months later three
months later I'll check in with them and
it's like subscribe for car repair tips
and then a couple months later they're
all over the place they have two reviews
of movies they have two gameplay Call of
Duty videos and then they have a video
on how to stay motivated and be a better
public speaker I'm like what the heck
are you doing like what what what is
this channel
you're you're inconsistently posting
your brand is all over the place there's
game playthroughs there's you on camera
the message is is what even is your
message your message is constantly
changing
another one's your energy just meaning
that I don't just mean your energy on
camera because you might have different
moves moods and Vibes I mean that the
energy people get from you is consistent
like when when I hope when people watch
think media they get a consistent
experience that's another word for it
you listen to the think media podcast
there's a consistent experience here
you're hopefully consistently getting
value we're not going to do it every
time
we're not going to knock it out of the
park every time but hopefully and this
is literally numbers I like to use I
like to think about the value I'm going
to deliver on the think media podcast on
a scale from one to ten of course I
always want it to be 10 but I know it's
never going to always be 10. and so my
actual goal is that these episodes are
consistently bringing you a six seven
eight level of value I don't want to do
too many sixes in a row
the question would be and if this could
be subjective but a four or five maybe
shouldn't be posted definitely a three
two or one and this goes back to
listening to others sometimes I gotta
listen and be like huh I thought that
was better than it was or as clearer
than it was it's okay in fact I'd say
this you don't want to be fearful like
one mistake one episode is gonna like
tumble your whole empire
however what happens is organizational
drift
what happens is Drift from the
Excellence you once had the hustle you
once had the quality you used to have
the care you used to have as that stuff
drifts people start going man this
channel used to be good but it just
feels like their heart's not in it
anymore feels like they're not listening
just feels like and by the way if this
feels like a a heavy responsibility good
you have the audacity to want to make an
all-time living working from home with
passive reoccurring income so not only
can you be generous but that you have
freedom and choices for your family and
for travel you're trying to live the
YouTube dream life it should be a little
bit heavy which means you should be
challenged to continue to read and level
up and study and invest so that you can
bring value when people encounter you
Sean this sounds like work yeah
it's work on your own terms it's being
Your Own Boss but it still takes heart
and effort and excellence and so
consistency is that when people come to
your videos they are constantly getting
a six seven eight nine and hopefully ten
sometimes and very few sixes if people
can jump click on your videos for the
promise you make in your title and be
like that was solid seven I mean that's
the channel is really consistent even I
would rather be consistent over 10 years
than be flashy for 10 months I don't
even really want to do tens all the time
I just want you to always be like Sean
is solid think media they deliver that's
not the most exciting Channel Maybe
but man it's consistent watch I can
depend on them listen I can trust think
media
to post consistently
to bring a consistent message to bring
some consistent energy to bring
consistent topics and maybe some of the
episode stretch you don't even click on
every video that's that's a key not
every podcast interests you not every
video interests you on think media for
sure not every video because you may not
have that specific camera or that
specific editing software but the
promise of the channel overall on our
main channel the best tips and tools for
building your influence with online
video were consistent to that or at
least that's the goal listen if you
ignore this YouTube Tip you will regret
it later number six putting money first
in your audience second
we got to really learn this lesson
lately we've seen people violating their
values for fame or for money
and I don't know if they did it
intentionally and I actually don't know
if their values were this up front
you know maybe their values were Fame
and money at any cost but what can
happen is I want to assume that most
people are good-hearted and that they
just get sucked up into the momentum
sucked up into the views sucked up into
the opportunities like I'm a small town
kid College Dropout all of a sudden
you're having an offer from a big
company it's you're conflicted like it's
hard you're like I don't know they could
be good of course we saw a lot of
financial YouTubers to partner with FTX
that's an ongoing developing story of
course we saw Logan Paul a controvers
virtual figure for sure and this crypto
Zoo thing and at the time of me
recording this Not only was there a
three-part series from coffee Zilla on
it then there's his reaction there's he
said she said back and forth you know
the whole deal and the punch line is
that at the center of all of these
stories though there's people who are
really getting hurt in the process
investors that are getting cheated out
of money dishonesty that has Downstream
consequences for for people being hurt
again and the big deal is that viewers
lose trust with creators
so if you put money first of course in
the short term it may be better for you
but in the long term you'll regret it
you don't want to put your audience
second because remember your audience
when it comes to the crater economy is
all you have
I was recently talking to the think
media team and I said listen first of
all
our entire business is based on people
it's based on a love of people it's
based on helping people win we are an
education company we need to be obsessed
with people too we need to respect and
love and honor to understand that none
of us have jobs
if we are not putting our audience first
every Wednesday we do what's called love
bombs which is taking time on Zoom
together we just all on there we turn on
a little chill hop music I mute my mic
and we put 10 to 20 minutes on the clock
and we we spread out across our email
inboxes and our Facebook groups and our
DMS and I try to go as many places I go
to think media podcasts or I go to my
Instagram comments and we do this other
times throughout the week but it is a
non-negotiable on our calendar that we
are going to have scheduled time of
going to wherever we can that anyone's
left to comment
and liking it replying saying thank you
and either hitting as many as we can or
and this would all tell think media team
I'll say or spend all 10 minutes
replying to one person doing for one
which you wish you could do for all the
point is we want to put our audience
first and remember that our community is
everything and the key phrase here our
favorite phrase is thank you
Gary vaynerchuk wrote a book years ago
called the thank you economy so and I'll
admit think media team is amazing
there's no better team they're
absolutely incredible but I'll watch it
happen we get busy
that we get busy serving people and
doing the work but we can get so busy
that posts can go unresponded to
comments can go unresponded to and even
at the level we're at we cannot get to
all of them but the punch line I call
people back to and I love Gary for this
is saying thank you and I want to thank
you literally for like the fact that if
all you ever do is just listen to this
one podcast thank you for spending your
watch time minutes here on YouTube or on
an audio platform thank you for hitting
like on the video thank you for sharing
it with somebody if you've been a part
of the think media Community for years
seriously thank you or you're subscribed
to the podcast and if you've ever
clicked on an affiliate link or bought a
book or bought a course thank you like I
just sincerely just recognize that if
you aren't here right now or we're not
connecting then I can't do what I get to
do
and my hope is that I can spark a little
bit of that love and gratitude that she
would pass it along to your community
here would be the the other angle of
this never getting entitled
to thinking you deserve it never getting
entitled to thinking that uh you you are
better than or above
staying engaged and thanking your
community and never getting entitled
like you're entitled to money at the
sacrifice of your audience like you're
entitled to fame at the sacrifice of
putting your audience first because you
never want to forget the very people
that helped you get there and I'm sure
you've probably observed it but what's
scary is this is a lot more common than
most people even believe
right A lot of people get success and
they forget the people who brought them
there a lot of people get success and
they no longer honor the very people
that helped him get them there they no
longer they never they never said thank
you they never truly shared the
appreciation for for the individuals
that helped him and and I'll tell you
this I did not get here alone
and no YouTube like a YouTube Creator
I'm self-made no you aren't
you had to be made by your audience I'm
self-made you were made by your parents
I'm self-made you are created by God
like he set this whole thing in motion
no man is an island to himself we need
each other we need to depend on others
and even the most famous of influencer
only has influence because someone is
following and commenting and liking
their stuff this whole ecosystem of the
Creator economy is about community and
other people that are interconnected no
one is doing it all by themselves and
alone even if you're a solo Creator you
you're depending on the software you're
depending on YouTube itself how about
thank you YouTube thank you YouTube for
giving me a platform to upload on I'm
free to upload on free thank you Adobe
for giving me software a lot of thank
yous can be put out there I know I'm on
a rabbit Trail but I just want to
encourage you to spread more love it's
not about putting money first and your
audience second that's a mistake it's
about keeping your audience first and
appreciating and knowing that they are
the ones who are allowing you to do what
you do and I want to encourage you that
as you continue to Value them and dare I
say take your value of your community to
another level really good book and and
episode in the archives from my friend
Pat Flynn wrote a book called super fans
and just the things he would do to love
on and connect with and serve his
community that's the kind of energy and
position that you want to have finally
number seven trying to be somebody else
if you try to be somebody else it might
work in the short term but you're going
to regret it later don't try to be
somebody else you got to be you times
two
because you were also born and original
so it would be awful to die a copy but
the other problem with trying to be
somebody else is maybe you saw somebody
doing it a certain way and you saw that
it worked and maybe you're even sort of
good at imitating them the problem is
you're out of alignment
I remember a health teacher I had in
high school right before I got expelled
nonetheless from Christian School that's
a story for another day
um and he was telling me about integrity
which I did not have clearly that's why
I got it expelled and he said you know
Integrity comes from the word integer
which means whole which means one
integrity means living in alignment with
your values integrity means there's no
double two-facedness to you there's no
hypocrisy there's no you're one way on
camera you're different in real life
you're different people you're an actor
wearing a mask over here and you're
somebody different here now of course if
you're literally an actor and you do
skits you should probably you know have
uh it's okay to try to be somebody else
because you're that's literally the job
of an actor but I'm talking for us that
are personal brands that are putting our
own brand out there friend it just try
it's gonna build up way too much stress
and anxiety because you're trying to
keep up the show
if you want to have peace like a river
if you want to be secure if you want to
be able to be unafraid in any
environment
you don't want to have any lies you
don't want to have to ask who am I
supposed to be here
who am I supposed to be you just want to
be yourself
just authentically you
and the more you could double down on
your authenticity the better listen it
also might mean you might think I won't
grow as fast if I'm truly me or I won't
I won't be as famous or I won't make as
much money good I would much rather be
me
and live a healthy solid
maybe somewhat modest YouTube Creator
economy career
than to get super famous and get a bunch
of accolades
for being fake
if my option is to
make 60k a year and I know globally
could be I'm just picking a number
that'd be like a you could live on that
certain places in the United United
States pretty well you get to do what
you love work from home
I know that a lot of us we want to make
six figures and crush it but just for
reference point if it was about making
60k a year
versus
four hundred thousand dollars a year but
I have to sell out
but I have to compromise my values but I
have to try to be somebody else
but I don't get to be me and I
constantly am trying to keep up a show
or I just don't get to fully be me
what's more valuable money or just truly
being secure in your own skin and being
yourself
so a huge mistake I see people make that
if you ignore this tip you're going to
regret it later it's just trying to be
somebody else
and if you can double down on who you
are and honestly be you times two
because what's amazing is truly the most
impactful creators that also leave a
lasting Legacy are people that we
observe from the outside and are able to
say wow like there's something about
them they've tapped into the magic why
because they're in alignment congruency
and Alignment is Unstoppable when
someone's just truly themself
they're just they're the Overflow of who
they are they didn't have to make
anything up because it's who they are
it's who they've been becoming it's what
they develop and you know they are just
right in the center of the superpower
of their strengths and quirks and
geekiness and
and non-geekiness and Leadership or more
or being more goofy or being more quirky
or being more funny or being super
intellectual or being really charismatic
and energetic or being more monotonous
and kind of funny or being really dry
and cynical or being more uh you know
over the top and directly humorous
like who are you like what are the skill
sets and traits and parts of your
personality because when you are that
watch when people actually then see that
and they see who you are going back to
number five then you're consistently you
and this is what people can know like
you or not they know what they're gonna
get
and because you know who you are you
just keep showing up as you
and it's been said before and I'll say
it again
your Vibe will attract your tribe you're
in harmony
the the music you're playing in your
videos I mean metaphorically but if
you're a musician of course the actual
music
you know like the the harmony that you
emit into the world is just you who's
being you doing your thing being you and
one of the interesting things that some
marketing firms revealed as I was
studying Trends was that vulnerability
is a big YouTube Trend that people are
connecting more when people are more
vulnerable
so they're willing to let people see
their scars they're willing to let
people see and hear about their mistakes
they're going the opposite of wearing a
mask and they're going to the side of
actually it's not about airing your
dirty laundry although some people do
that or just being crazy vulnerable but
it's just about being more vulnerable
and more transparent double down on
vulnerability and transparency this year
not as a tactic as an opportunity to
create deeper connections with your
community and to just be more expressly
you and secondly they saw that
authenticity was a major Trend that what
we're looking for in a world where it
feels clickbaity and hype and like
people are wearing masks and they're
playing characters that when somebody is
truly them we are craving trust and
congruency we are hungry for people just
being authentic and we we just kind of
want to know who they are what they
stand for and so don't try to be someone
else hey if you want to uh connect with
us more and specifically if you want to
take advantage of this limited offer we
have on our signature course video
ranking Academy with a bunch of bonuses
at a special price that we only do a
couple times a year during our
challenges that is closing soon so
learnvideo2023.com Link in the show
notes if you want to check that out I
want to thank you for being a part of
the think media podcast Community
wherever you listen to this if you can
rate review like and comment that means
the world to me and what did you like
best did any of these stand out to you
and which one do you want to work on the
most and I also want to encourage you to
subscribe because we have some powerful
episodes and Powerful guests coming to
the think media podcast this year
whether you subscribe on audio or video
I love you I respect you and I'm super
grateful that you're part of this
community we're on a mission to help 10
000 purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with YouTube and video thanks for being
a part of the mission we are here to
serve you and help you on your YouTube
Journey so until the next episode we
will talk soon